а матчі готова Україна 5 на компроміси
щоб запросити його low року диво
припаяні йому вогню
компроміс з ес і point of the medal of
fun крім чує термінологія для мене моя
значення g готова русева каналу ти свої
зуби в'язання в рамках мінських біля води
мінську відходу зі свого роду план мирного
врегулювання конфліктів так що ви
хоче а рука то явно прямо помру
що випадково ви робота ви застосовуєте
стріляли ну і дозволяє mbc
контролювати територію дозволяє л б
з е контролю вати вид у будинку сил в
лають старець
ви дозволяє фбс я контролювати і
чисту кордону через річку ми вашому
приплив оружня то російських регулярних
весь після чого ми пачино це вириті
правильніше то справедливі вибори на
донбасі 300 talkin' bout
а про що made in будинок азарус я не здається і
цигун і прокидаюся у занурення мінських
духовних ти чого ніс і скаже і частиною
giving up all of examples в них можна
навести кілька пригладив заразна
донбасі перебуваючи близько 2000 верстати та
дуже багато різьбленого оружня ми можемо
роздрукувати підготовку до вибору
розуму краще на донбасі такий посмішку
кільки обрали або стильним шляхом до
через український російський кордон та
кіно та застосовується
кожного дня в зоні конфлікту 50 60 обидва
і 70 обстрілявши через бурхливих вийдеш бро
і то іншим можна казахи бутік виповз із
цієї конькової ланч або кондерів
Ефект статусу України заявляють що на
хіба ви не можете навіть переконані у плив
на донбасі нібито 100 ват і потім пучок
дзвонова people хуа
independent викинутий за такі ляканий
жар
там не травня на закладених людей зовні
росію весь килим то вся обстановка там
криється за російської з русей там процес
російські весь кив ти російські
спецслужби з ваших питав вас там
новачок заарештують російську валюту експе
ви
enzo sense of a
cummins та завершена сербенчук джип
можеш любу
антимайдан бас weather in formal
за расу нічого не вибивається на
офіційні переговори частоту 1 на
донбасі чим може у росіян це
українці застуду machines ab щасливих
of normandy fallout we have годину 200 ппш
у нас є норманський формат ми по ви
думав це хімічних у ось там і по
виведуть риму і тасячи нормальному формати
алла росія затягує шас банани так
монстру випробувай кінного ти думала насті
а просто джека і подалі і до
стабілізації в Україні та намажатися як
ти треба стабілізувати обстановку
впливали плейну time not шайн диво
ввечері йдуть їх вибори в Європі і
в США
у Росії чому вірити що c можемо від 3 до
стабілізація все ще вийти Росії
нам треба що бруси лаялася біля букви q
на ній мінських у ось сам хан біль і
встромляє
і сам цьому санкції мати важливі ви
значення солідарність мої важливого
значення політичний розшук
такий же їжу ж важливим і анд звинувачувати ваша
чудини його він мінськ бекасів z77 патент
щоб робити risen patent and політика
спрощується досі світ сьогодні
чим не знає його ще можна кропом у
період був про поліпшення автономії то
виборі у дати автономію проросійським
сепаратистам уті чистими українами
чому голосує і вибори ось фото затону
in and if i have я костюми на дому
донбасу автономію я kotova хочеш
Росія
ти будеш лях до федералізації україни
та й ослабла не та розділу не сіла
росія та прани
забуду лаги темизація російської
протекторату на донбасі після звідси
стратегії та розпорошуючи в тому щоб за що
всередину протекторат назад до складу
україни в кості тур янського коня авто
за 6 в цей же з трохи вже тут
підточує б ключовик rain мов
відійди україна вже не гостро. з чудилі
він мінськ українська стратегія поля гоіл
базу на не мінських домовленостей та
цілих ліжок що ви мало що ванесса рубає
відчувши крем того важливим пунктом я
припаяні не обстріл щоб ridata
контроль над ситуацією в обох їжі
данії поліцейської місії
щоб вивести російську зброю з
донбасу після цеху можна буде шато
підготовку до дроту не рясних і
справедливих виборів задумають і побратиму
істина c трапиться застава і часто бал
фарбую
все залагоджувати виду росії на донбасі
nemo і на закладених на вигляд росії людей
цьому на донбасі і тут усе закласти
відро за його українського президента
Петра Порошенка ще до готовності вести
війни stand of loss ти мобілізацію
викликаю за неспокій ним дуже поважає і
ви зараз я можна закликати слідувати
кільця флейти соло як президент колеса
і президенти читку сказав так що
ситуація з тут але повершити цю дірку
гляну там уже вивести виганяв військового
стануть
менших заходив там розуму за ви не
повністю просвітить особливо при п на нього
вогню чин цей позов на росію ви канал
відібрати києву води
доликами а осел годинник tfa чуб у добре
дивом мінськ і за господь і доступу
bcn чепець про син термін і треба ти був
ступ спеціальні монітори нової місії
рублів світла поліцейські місії на
донбасі
тільки в овець або дві тисячі танків і
бронемашин ми б ви не мотатися у зброї
не друкуємо контролем на крафти було б
вид дроту та його назад у русі тому
що нас проводиться в сиру сиська оружня
потім провести вільно з провідні вибір
та піт міжнародним control of thinking
for men так і сиплеться ти швидко
саліцилат біля пляжу